fall sommes en norvège maintenant
premier pas vers une levée progressive
des restrictions dans le royaume après
cinq semaines de fermeture les créations
rouvert hier matin une décision
officiellement justifiée par des
considérations sanitaires les enfants il
serait largement épargnée par le coni 19
ce qui devrait faciliter le retour au
travail des parents wasyl avec françois
tiscali
chaudement emmitouflés les enfants
arrivent au portail d'une crèche du nord
d'aussi haut certains heureux de
retrouver leurs copains jouent déjà dans
le bac à sable tandis que d'autres
s'agrippe longuement au bras de leurs
parents dans la cour le personnel en
chasuble jaune fluo accueille les
enfants pour limiter les risques de
contamination
l'entrée des bâtiments est désormais
interdite au public mais aucun masque à
l'horizon c'est là pour tous les parents
laissent leurs enfants habituellement
ils vont à l'intérieur mais maintenant
ils doivent attendre dehors attendre le
personnel déposer les enfants à
l'extérieur et non à l'intérieur de la
crèche autres consignes des autorités
les plus jeunes enfants jusqu'à 3 ans
sont rassemblés en groupes de trois sous
la responsabilité d'un adulte
ce plus âgés jusqu'à 6 ans en groupe de
six avec interdiction de se mélanger les
uns les autres des mesures assez
rassurante pour les parents à la maison
nous avons choisi de suivre les
recommandations des autorités sanitaires
alors si elle recommande de rouvrir les
crèches où nous sommes convaincus que
tout est fait pour préserver notre santé
bien sûr le risque zéro n'existe pas
mais je suis d'accord pour dire qu'il
était temps de le faire
c'est très réglementé comme nous avons
pu le constater lorsque nous sommes
arrivés à la crèche et que nous l'avons
déposé
tout est sous contrôle et bien planifiée
il est évident que lille voulait pas
exposer vos enfants aux dangers mais je
vois que d'autres pays scandinaves ou
vers leur école comme en suède en
islande la finlande tous les
gouvernements et les experts disent que
les enfants ne sont pas vraiment explosé
à virer alors nous leur faisons
confiance et nous verrons comment cela
se passe
une décision qui ne fait toutefois pas
l'unanimité
les plus sceptiques ont lancé une
campagne sur les réseaux sociaux
intitulé mon enfant ne doit pas être un
lapin de laboratoire pour le coc vite 19
recueillant lundi matin plus de 28 mille
signatures lundi prochain ce seront les
écoles primaires qui rouvriront leurs
portes aux plus jeunes écoliers